around five thousand migrants have
entered spain's
north african enclave of ceuta some
swimming almost two kilometers along the
coastline from neighboring morocco
one man drowned in the crossing during a
record one day influx of people to the
territory
is one of two populated spanish enclaves
on
mainland africa authorities are sending
security reinforcements to the area amid
worsening relations between
spain and morocco
it started in the early hours of the
morning
groups of young men made the risky swim
from morocco to the neighboring spanish
territory of ceyuta
exhausted they then reported to
authorities for processing
as the day went on the tide dropped
exposing an
easy path around the border wall that
allowed whole families and miners to try
the crossing
some even resorting to an inflatable
boat
it's the biggest arrival of migrants
ever seen in ceuta
more than a thousand children were said
to be among the new arrivals
authorities are overwhelmed by the
influx
madrid says they are urgently sending
more resources to the region
many of the moroccan migrants celebrated
making it across the border
hoping to start a better life inside the
boundaries of the european union
but there's a high chance those
celebrations will be short-lived
spain's foreign minister says
authorities have already started sending
people back to morocco
it follows the arrival of more than a
hundred migrants in april
everyone except unaccompanied minors
were deported
you